We're going to start with what is compact. And so let's consider a common problem in computing.
We have a set of things like cards, and we want to filter that set to get a subset that we care about.
This comes up all the time.
We might decide that we only want to do computation on the diamonds from this set of cards,
and take all the other cards and throw them away.
We might select students from the roster of this class
who have perfect scores on the programming assignments.
My background is in computer graphics, for instance.
So an example there, we might have a lot of objects to draw in a scene,
but we only want to keep those that actually intersect the screen.
We call this operation compact because we're compacting
the large input set of potentially many items, into something smaller.
Another word for this is filter. Now, why do we want to do this?
Well, if we only care about a subset of the input, and we want to run
some computation on that input, it makes more sense to throw away the items that we don't care about,
and only compute on the objects that we do care about.
We can rightfully assume this is both cheaper to compute and takes less space.
We have a set of objects S 0, S 1, S 2, S 3, S 4 and so on.
And we have what we call a predicate, and that's this line here.
Predicate is a function that inputs an S object and returns true or false for that object.
For instance, this predicate we're looking at here is, "is my index even?"
So for S 0, S 2 and S 4, the predicate returns true. For S 1 and S 3, the predicate returns false and so on.
We want to calculate S filtered by this predicate.
So we only keep those objects in S for which the predicate is true.
So what form do we want the output of this filter of this compact operation to be?
We have a choice of how to do it. We can either have a sparse output, or a dense output.
For the sparse output, each element tracks to its same position in the output,
and if an input has a false predicate we just put some sort of nole element in there.
Alternatively, we could have a dense output, where all the elements for which the predicate is true
are then packed together into the output so they're all sitting right next to each other.
There aren't any gaps in the output.
In general, we want the output of a compact operation to be dense. And let me tell you why.
Let's go back to one of the examples I cited earlier.
Selecting the 13 diamonds from a deck of 52 playing cards and running
a procedure called compute card on each of the diamonds, we can structure this code in 1 of 2 ways.
We could either wrap our computation in a big if clause--
so what we're doing here is on each card we check if it's a diamond,
and if it is a diamond then we run computecard.
Otherwise, we do nothing. This is the sparse approach.
Or, we could run a compact on the deck of 52 cards
to get back 13 diamonds, by running compact on the cards, using the is diamond predicate,
and then run a map on the compacted cards, calling compute card only on the diamonds.
So note that the sparse computation, on the left side, is going to launch 52 threads, 1 per card,
and 39 of those threads will be idle.
The dense computation, on the other hand, incurs the cost of the compact,
but then in the map step, it only launches 13 threads.
If the compute card routine is at all expensive,
then the sparce approach loses because we have to launch 4 times as many threads.
Three quarters of those threads are going to be idle,
while the other quarter of the threads are actually doing useful work.
But because both idle and non-idle threads are running in log-step,
we're still paying the run time costs of having 4 times as many threads
Therefore, generally, you prefer the dense approach especially when this computation is expensive.